I'm not sure if you guys remember this
is magician named David Blaine it's
funny because this [ __ ] will say
anything and do whatever you want and
all the white people just let him do you
like magic I'm gonna touch your tit
watch you do that you a you do to see
what happens
uh yeah go away here's a magic trick
tickle car the minute one single [ __ ]
yourself oh wait is going on YouTube now
I've got a notion something people don't
seem to have a sense a [ __ ] common
courtesy I'm not I'm not sure if it's
because I grew up brothers [ __ ] or when
you call under privilege okay it's
brokers for them but then I rolled out
go out with that don't seem to apply to
anyone else so I'm here to prevent y'all
can you ask what's in certain situations
so you already know what it is lg
optimus get it let's go
common courtesy rule number one and
ain't what you said it's about the way
you said it
just because you said please and thank
you at the end of a sentence doesn't
mean you said it politely like either
[ __ ] that workout yeah [ __ ] may Teddy
[ __ ] nipple crooked penis mother
[ __ ] kill your pal duh [ __ ] you just
say to me please thank you well never
mind then but yesterday I was having a
phone conversation outside of a
restaurant and this dude came up to me
and said hey you're being really loud
it's annoying keep it down please you
see is that the words you know what you
said it's the toe and the way that you
said it do you wanna tell you about your
bougie ass with all the attitude through
this table I'm amazed with it right now
I already thought a forty six way to
accenting your ass piece of attention
I'm a tie yo dick to a piece of steak
and Linda's [ __ ] swim inside of a lion's
cage let me ask you something how do you
expect me to walk away from that
situation
we're not go up at that point I have two
options stab you or seven that's about
it but [ __ ] you look yeah awesome
Jesus
oh they chopped off your hands and then
the [ __ ] jumps up with it this this
ain't trending at all is it I don't
looks like I'm swinging a dildo is [ __ ]
yeah
I'm not somebody you wanna [ __ ] with I'm
crap yeah
takes up I know a few people Prince
novel [ __ ] you up
you don't want stick it out mmm that's
right you heard me I said in my crown
that's your ass whippin on layaway and
what's up tre yes me date them so I need
you to [ __ ] somebody up when you get out
there 32 years
Oh am I gonna miss you not you dangerous
I can't associate with you rule number
two if I don't know you don't talk to me
like you know me I like meeting new
people and in general I'm a nice
[ __ ] you will ever meet
damn it but I hate it when you just met
somebody and they start saying personal
[ __ ] to you that only your close friends
a lock say for example just because one
of my boys Buster that you love me don't
pay you a little visit he calls me fat I
tell me look like the inside of hippos
[ __ ] and you know we come on baby but
if I just met you when you jump into our
conversation like today would you do a
cheer with your fat ass Oh what
something you want talking about my
weight with y'all hairy ass upper lip
that's right don't [ __ ] both y'all
family [ __ ] this [ __ ] it's common
sense I just fed you I ain't comfortable
with you like that but a clown on a dude
you just dead [ __ ] I don't know you I
will hurt you deep with your eyes are
hella far apart and [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's a sign that you hug these [ __ ]
even your eyes are running away from
your face bro number three if you like
the balls enough to say some [ __ ] you
best explain yourself I hate it when
somebody [ __ ] up and the best response
they got is what's your problem bro
you ever notice when they [ __ ] up that
like they would never part of what just
went down I don't get it I didn't do
anything bro sir if you didn't do
anything why the [ __ ] is my foot about
two centimeters away from being lodged
up in your [ __ ]
it's gotta look that situation when that
punk [ __ ] bullies out one dude and he
finally stands up for himself and then
all son he's a private he says [ __ ] like
well calm down I was just playing a
Pharrell were playing a game
why don't you play a new game it's
called hide and go [ __ ] yourself look
you know it was looking don't violence
if I'm telling you right now
you out there not everybody will be like
me just one day you might push somebody
over logic didn't grow up the same way
that you did and trust me when you get
your ass beat it just might change your
opinion happen to me a couple times
without deserve it
maybe punk [ __ ] you look ya'll ran out
of pepper spray a howl of pain in your
eyes up like this what's going on
YouTube so check it out so if you guys
haven't noticed I started up a another
show on the VEVO channel called the
common show if you guys haven't heard
about it already let me just give you a
breakdown of what's about it's about me
I'm hosting the show and uh basically I
get to rag on people who leave stupid
and dumb comments on music videos hope
y'all like it go check it out let me
know what your face and if you don't
like you like it anyways because don't
have to feel it let get you know what am
I saying
hey start it again see by the time you
brought all that me exam how do you
expect me to walk away from that
situation uh-oh
oops wasn't me no somebody else even
though I'm the only one in the room
anyways I need you to [ __ ] somebody when
you can [ __ ] somebody with the rozzers
say you want to show me mad if I don't
you magically disappear you want to show
me magic why don't you get a job [ __ ]